i think you've said that the word theme
has been misused extensively
when it comes to film and television but
i believe you've also said that beware
of the
with the simple one-liner yeah
it's a theme is something that is
misunderstood by a percentage of people
[Music]
one of the things that my playwriting
teacher
pointed out to me back when i was
learning this stuff and
he he explained it and then he said
this is really important make sure you
absorb this
and he said the way in which the
protagonist
resolves the dilemma expresses the theme
of the story and
it's very very clear because
the resolution is where the whole story
comes together
and the completion of the story
completes the magic spell on the
audience
which crystallizes the mood that they go
home in
like in a romantic comedy it's been fun
and fresh but also the romance falling
apart and things
getting troubled and then finally coming
together in the end
and usually you feel happy and in love
at the end if it's done right
and all of that was skillfully
orchestrated by the writer and
the filmmakers and the theme
also comes through that that which is
being
said organically by the story
comes together in the ending
and so if you look at the protagonist's
act of resolution of the dilemma
and look at the way in which the
protagonist resolves the dilemma
that enables you to put your finger on
the theme so for instance
if you uh let's say
you know you know what if with our story
about derek
that say that
he finds he creates
a third way out of the dilemma
in which he's neither trapped by the
demands of his company
nor by the demands of
the blackmailer or whatever it ends up
being
and neither one is a good way out
and by thinking on his feet and maybe
working with
skyler he comes up with a creative way
to skate through
this horrible trap that he was in
and so if you look at not you look at
what he does
but you look at the way in which he does
it
it's about like thinking creatively and
realizing what he really needs in life
where he was always denying his own
needs
and lying to himself and like that he's
finally brutally honest with himself
and is genuinely in love with her even
though
she has betrayed him but she's also been
a victim
and she's changed and he's grown and
he's able to
synthesize a new life for himself
in the process of figuring out how to
get out of the trap that
all of that is what the story is about
thematically it's about creating a new
life for yourself and finding a way out
of hell
and powering out of a skid
and you can see that that
creative type of resolution of taking
command of his life and
powering out of a bad situation
is what the story is about thematically
and what's interesting about
being able to articulate the theme
that's emerging organically from a story
is that you
often only start with a sense of it
like in looking at that type of possible
resolution for derrick
i can see it
and sort of talk around it and describe
it in a bunch of different ways like i
just did
like i just said it about 10 different
ways but my
my ability to articulate it crisply and
cleanly
is not there yet because
it you have to live with it for a while
and
look at what the audience leaves with
they leave with a sense
of that theme in their gut in their soul
and if you stop them on the way out and
ask them to articulate the theme
they probably couldn't they just have it
at a gut level it's in them
[Music]
so it has a lot to do
you want to be able to dwell with a
partially formed understanding of
something
as a crucial step
in synthesizing your understanding
people are very uncomfortable with
partial solutions
they always want to go no i need to have
the whole thing in my in a nutshell
so they don't like partial understanding
it kind of freaks people out
but as a creative writer you need to
get comfortable with that because so
often you're feeling your way through
things
where you're beginning to understand it
at a gut level
but you have no capacity whatsoever at
first for articulating
it and maybe you finally
just got a handle on your theme
and your writing partner comes in the
room and you go like i got it i got it
your writing partner was like so what is
it what is it spit it out and you're
like
i can't yet i got it leave me alone get
out of my face
let me just sit here with it because i
got it and people are feeling creatures
that
long before speech people just
felt animals do that were feeling
creatures
and so the ability to
look at the res look at the the
protagonist's resolution
and look at the way in which he or she
resolves the dilemma
will put you right on the theme that's
actively emerging
from organically in your story and it
may be
diametrically opposed to what you
thought the theme of your story was
going to be
starting with a sense of theme can often
be
troublesome because you can end up being
preachy
and trying to dictate that to the
viewers or the readers
as opposed to that which organically
emerges as the story takes on a life of
its own
the characters take on a life of their
own and you have to be able to
if you're still stuck saying that the
theme is what you set out to have it be
you may be the one that's missing the
boat
the view if the viewers see that movie
they'll get it organically and carried
away in their gut
and think about it for a while if it's
deep and compelling
and it may affect how they interact with
people for the rest of their lives
like they never yell at their kids again
for the rest of their life or something
like that
because something was awakened in them
even if they can't explain it
maybe maybe later they'll be able to but
the important thing is that you
changed them through a complete
the complete action of a compelling
story
so being able to
have a good strong sense of theme that's
really emerging from your story
is critical because you as the writer
need to be able to
be in touch with the theme that is
coming through the story
if you're still stuck on what you
thought it was going to be then you're
missing the boat
you're missing the chance to work with
the real theme
reinforce it utilize it
and so your story will tend to be weaker
or you're out of touch with what your
story is actually doing
you know it's like you raise your kid
and my kid's going to be a doctor my
kid's going to be a doctor and you still
see that
because you're intent on seeing that but
if you look at the reality of what your
kid is doing you'd be like
he's a jazz musician holy crap i thought
he was a
medical school but no he is genuinely a
jazz musician
so it's about what you want to see
versus what's really there and
theme is huge because
you want to be able to connect
to the theme that's emerging from your
story
reasonably early in the process
you could see that with the derrick
story i went right to dilemma
and i was all and once i'm working with
dilemma a bit i'm looking ahead to
crisis
because that gives shape and and focus
to the theme the theme is going to
converge at the point of crisis
and force it is decision in action when
there's like
maybe 10 or 15 minutes left in the movie
and then the protagonist actively
resolves the dilemma
once and for all that's the ending of
the story
and then the way in which the
protagonist resolves the dilemma enables
you to put your finger on the theme
that's actively emerging
through that story and you'll start
early in the development process of your
story
but you've already got a tentative
statement or a tentative handle on your
theme
you want to that's why i said beware of
the clever one-liner
because if experts in creativity say
there's often ten
right answers to a question and if you
seize on one of those and say that's the
answer
then you miss out on all the other
layers of complexity
so again it comes back to
people's discomfort with a partially
formed understanding
they it freaks them out to dwell in that
area where they
sort of understand it but not really
but that's the bread and butter of a
writer where you're
gradually morphing through evolving
ideas
and once you can
feel the theme and live with it
and look at all the aspects of your
thought story
through the lens of your gradually
evolving
understanding of the theme it will
inform the whole
story because the theme really is what
the story is about
it's that they call the governing or a
governing idea
or the underlying philosophy of the
story or that which is being said by the
story
and it may be again it may be the
opposite of what you set out to say
or what you even want it to say
but that's what's really coming across
to the audience
and that's price said that
the theme well let me read you this
quote from him
yeah so
so this is price writing in 1908
about playwriting so i was talking about
plays but it's it's exactly the same
stuff
the highest form of play involves the
philosophy of life
so that if th so that if the theme is
not worth considering
there is usually little substance in a
play
with a theme your play will be about
something theme does not stand alone
no principle does mere theme will never
make a play
but it is a definite something it
furnishes a spiritual atmosphere and the
philosophy of the play
it gives the clue to the actual shaping
of the play the tone depends upon it
it is the largest unit of the play
that's a very interesting statement that
the theme is the largest unit
of the play that's really interesting
for instance
the biggest organ in your body is your
skin
so it's that kind of thing the theme
is is not infects the whole story that's
not the right word but it's
it's spread throughout the whole story
it
determines the shape and the tone of the
story
and all that stuff so it's the ability
to come to grips with it is important
and
gradually as you spend time living with
it your ability to articulate it will be
enhanced
until it kind of crystallizes and then
you're like oh
yeah now i can explain it quite clearly
like sydney pollock could say
the way that becoming a woman made a man
out of michael dorsey
like there's a really crisp clear
statement of what that story is about
thematically
and it and it helped him so much
and it gave a shape and a tone and
helped him communicate with the actors
and all that stuff
so it's a uh
very powerful aspect of the story
and the basics of it is you don't want
to rush it
let yourself dwell with a partially
formed understanding of it
and it will gradually gel and then
crystallize
but not if you rush it
you